all right thank everybody for coming out
we got a good crowd tonight and tonight
I wanted to return to the pawn structure
series so every month I try to cover a
different pawn structure which i think
is kind of fundamental to understanding
lots of chess positions especially
people you know they spend a lot of time
learning openings but especially at the
beginning when you're starting out in
chess and I mean it goes on throughout
your chess career that you need to sort
of fundamentally understand pawn
structures and the way that the pawns
are located on the board is going to
tell you where you want to put your
pieces and how you want to organize your
attacks and which pawn breaks you should
be playing for so tonight I will be
taking a recommendation this was the
first one that I saw when I was looking
to see what you guys on youtube wanted
to see so again if you want to see a
pawn structure just comments below let
me know and maybe you'll get featured
here on the show this is for Pioche both
rah who wants Kings Indian main line
pawn structure and I thought that'd be
an interesting one so we will jump over
to here and that we will in this
position we're going to go ahead and
we're going to look at a couple
different things that can occur in this
pawn structure so this is sort of the
starting point of any Kings Indian kind
of imagine the Kings aren't on the board
we're just going to be focusing here on
the pawns and as you can see White has a
little bit more space in these kinds of
positions black is probably fianchetto
the bishop and what can generally happen
in these types of positions is one of
three ways to break the tension in the
center the most popular structure that
will arise from here and we'll have a
look at it is the move d5 white just
takes more space and now white has a lot
more space on the Queen side so that's
where he'll be playing for the rest of
the game for example we might play b4 c5
and we can open files on the Queen side
that's where we'll be focusing all of
our attention black on the other hand
has more space on the Kings side
sponsor
this way so he'll be trying to play
moves like f5 and often in these
positions when white is Castle kingside
black can go in for a big attack and you
can launch all of these pawns and try to
open up lines on the kingside so very
often the question is will blacks attack
succeed will he get there in time and be
able to land a lethal blow or a white
crash throw in the queenside and
ultimately get enough counter play to
win the game another way that you can
change the pawn structure here let me
make a nothing move here for white is
black can take on d4 this is not you
know very common way to play but it's
been played by some very serious people
out there and we can imagine probably a
knight maybe a queen takes back here and
we get sort of the maroc C bind
structure but it's a little bit
different there's a deep on and no epon
and let's let me just I'll just whoop
off-screen somehow yeah can't do it but
okay if you imagine that we took this
pawn back in your head there's there's a
couple different things that black can
do in this type of structure one is he
can play moves like c6 and he can bring
this Queen in often the Queen can come
in here and cause some problems and
sometimes black is able to win a pawn
because for example if we can imagine
this in our head
if the Queen's on b4 and we play b3 to
protect our B pawn black can put his
pawn all the way down and you can try to
create a target here so often this
happens and sometimes black is able to
win upon on the Queen side this is one
possible strategy for him and what often
happens is well then your Queen and some
of your other pieces are all the way
over there so sometimes while you're
winning the pawn over here you get
checkmated over here but sometimes
you're up upon so people like to do it
because it's very dynamic another way to
play again with c6 is to insert the move
a six and b5 that's another break and
you want to start to tear down this bind
that white has which is also why the
third way is f5 and
- you know obviously it's kind of a
committal move but okay maybe we can
open it up and break the bind apart
another thing that might happen for
black after the move see six very often
he'll try to play to move d5 and get rid
of this weak D pawn so that's one way
that people play and if Black gets it in
successfully then he can be doing great
but other times you know doesn't work it
just depends on the exact position we
have in front of us
and okay-y tries to play he tries to not
trade a lot of pieces in this kind of
line because he has more space and if he
can successfully put all of his pieces
on active squares and avoid trades then
usually he's doing pretty well and the
last structure here that we're going to
look at will actually look at it in our
first game is sort of the exchange
variation which I don't think a lot of
Club players play but I know there's at
least one guy that plays here in all of
our tournaments and he has a very good
success rate he just always plays the
exchange variation here of the King's
Indian and goes very well with it and
okay white obviously has more space but
just looking at the pawn structure one
thing you'll notice is black has good
control here over d4 also d3 is kind of
weak so sometimes we can use that square
but the big difference is if white ever
gets a piece to d5 it can always be
kicked away eventually with a move like
c6 that does however you know give up
the d6 square and sometimes so we've got
to be a little bit careful but this is a
more permanent kind of square imagine a
good knight there versus some
LightSquared bishop or something and
that would be just a crushing position
so that's obviously that would be the
dream endgame if you were playing this
is black
I got a knight here and you got like a
bishop here and your pawns are all on
light squares that be sort of the dream
here for black well actually we'll go
we'll just get to it here let's jump to
our first game
and I want to show this this was a game
between Silvio deny love versus garry
kasparov it was just here in town and
this was played in the World Junior
Championship from 1980 okay and in this
game we're not going to focus so much on
the opening but here we have it so the
exchange Kings Indian which is sort of
an underestimated weapon in my opinion
because I think a lot of people don't
actually know how to play this against
us as white and you know normally when
black plays King's Indian you know you I
don't know you know you normally get
wild attacking games this is going to be
a lot more positional okay and so Queens
were exchanged notice that you can't yet
take on e5 because Knight takes e4 and
there's some discovered stuff on that
suspicious diagonal and okay we're not
focused too much on the opening the main
move here is rook to e8 in the game
Kasparov chose Knight B to d7 castling
long was probably a little bit better
but we're going to get to a simple
position here where okay he achieved the
two bishops and Gary made an interesting
choice here you might think you know
this guy's doing nothing go here but he
actually decided to rid himself of the
pin so he got out of the pen that was
his idea
White Castle which is probably an
inaccuracy and now here black played
Knight to c5 and so this is going to be
the first interesting moment of the game
so there's pressure on the e pawn and
what white decided to do here was okay a
move that has serious consequences for
the remaining part of this game so this
here he decided the only way to get rid
of it I mean perhaps you can consider
sacking that pawn but he took this
bishop
okay and we take back and you did not
want to get rid of that bishop in the
position like this so you can see now we
have the potential in the future to land
a knight on d4 and control that square
in some lines so this is you know
actually quite a concession the question
now is how will gary exploit this and
okay he does it beautifully even when he
was a junior so we're gonna we're going
to see how this totally impacts the game
okay
so he protects the pawn and in these
lines a very typical move for black
I mean if it's White's turn maybe I can
kick your night away if the move like b4
so a very typical move a5 just keeping
this square available for your knight
and will decide where we want to go a
little bit later okay he brought his
rook in now Gary played a very nice move
I quite like and okay I guess here - I'd
like to just do a little planning
exercise I just wonder and there's got
to be multiple right answers it's not
like there's one move in this position
but let's just think about all of our
pieces and see if we can come up with an
optimal setup here as black so go ahead
and pause your video I'm going to give
these guys a little bit of time just a
plan I think this is a very interesting
position already and in a minute I ask
you guys how you would a sort of assess
this position and what your plan might
be you want to somehow open the C file
move like b5 okay which seems entirely
reasonable I don't think it's a bad move
at all it's actually the move in okay
and again I always prepare these I show
them to like somebody and I see what
they would say and that was the move one
of our highest-rated instructors came up
with okay and after we do this
I can play King b1 if I remember that's
the right way to do this and this
actually is okay for black I mean this
is you know a very valid way of
continuing
but now that is - on to its I don't know
if you're actually really going to get a
an attack going over here and I'm still
wondering what this what this guy is up
to no okay I mean you you played b5 it's
an okay move yeah and just looking at
your pieces which piece do you think you
need to find a better home for the
bishop yeah so okay we begin imagining
okay I got to do something with that guy
and we begin visualizing where would the
optimal place be on the board and okay
his his vision was quite deep here and I
you know in general I like to think of
it as teleportation you might think of
it however you think about in your head
but I try to pick it up in my head and I
like begin trying out all these squared
where do I want to be and you want to
try to find the best home for your
bishop
and in this position gary played rook e8
we'll see the point of this in a second
and rook e8 conquering the D file you
heard me right it's actually he had a
very long plan to actually get control
of the D file by not starting there the
D file yeah can you believe it that's
what I said you know you can't say crazy
things on the Internet
so you know it must be right but yeah
obviously it's a very tempting move but
he's deciding he's going to use this
square for his bishop so we can we can
begin imagining where that guy might go
and how it might influence certain files
on the board so he went back in Bishop
d8 where is he going
okay so this bishop is going to
re-emerge somewhere on this side a4 and
now we're beginning to see where the
bishop is going he decided to put his
Bishop on a5 so okay at home if you
thought you know of this very powerful
Rhema nuvaring then congratulations
because now this actually this diagonal
makes it really hard for black to get
control of the D file so now he just
goes ahead and he takes it okay so there
was the trade
and he takes with the rook which you'll
notice hangs this pawn here however this
will be very very dangerous to take just
letting my rook into d2 like this yes
the audience is mostly just shaking
their heads yeah just don't do it okay
minimum I can take on f2 I could start
with f6 so that's not something that you
should allow in this position so okay he
went Bishop to h3 so the night is still
controlling the D 2 square f6 in black
has emerged with a better position here
he's just clearly better he you know
we'll see what he can do with these
active pieces but all of his pieces are
superior to any of the ones of white so
in this position now and he's very
patient too in this game he plays a very
patient move just a little probing move
after sorry in this position I just
slowed improving my just move my king up
Knight d3 the idea is to go to b4 and
you know you have difficulties
protecting this and your back rank so he
provoked a3 it just goes back okay just
slowly improving now I have control over
b3 and what are you not doing anything
so all right h4 maybe you can get some
counter play over there I don't think so
White's just kind of shuffling around
and I believe is here he actually plays
a very very good move a very good move
here uh and again you can keep being
patient you know you could Knight b3 you
could play some you know other slow move
you could do nothing move your king up
you could do a whole variety of things
what I'm wondering if you guys can
figure out what Gary did here and it's
it's remarkable so that's the hint you
can pause at home and it can be
sometimes hard to gauge you know should
I do something or should I just keep
being patient well here you find
something very concrete do we have any
ideas as to what he played here maybe
three is yeah just okay just a nice
normal move and this certainly is just a
very good move and you can just keep
waiting and white will also you know
maybe keep waiting do you have any
concrete plan after this move or give a
you have an idea let me make just try
not to do anything did you have more
after this
okay so you want to go here um okay and
I think in general maybe this I know I
kinda I kind of still like going here
because in some lines I can play Brooke
2d - that's a huge part of this position
your night is kind of tied down because
okay we can go here so I'm going to move
my rook somewhere I'm just gonna go all
the way back try to be as safe as I can
yeah you're trying to get some threat
here and I mean yeah maybe you maybe you
will um I don't think this actually
helps me at all because you know you
have 93 but uh yeah I mean yeah I think
you can probably just go get this guy if
you sometimes though I mean there's also
interesting ideas I can go like this and
try to like somehow get some some fake
counterplay and on I think just this is
just the better diagonal for the bishop
so he didn't put his Bishop on b6 I
think this is just a better diagonal and
a big clue as to what he played here
I'll just highlight the square the
problem is this Knight if we could get
that night to go away then work to d2
becomes a very serious threat yeah I
want yeah yeah he played g5 I'm gonna
play g4 tonight's gonna move and okay so
he took all right welcome Ken we started
well we started a little late I mean
theoretically at UH 6:30 that's fine um
okay and you might be thinking what if I
take here which is one thing you could
do to my Ben's not here you can't get
this wild can West cameo on tape they're
so rare these days
thanks for coming again um well here I
guess also here both I assume about
anything that goes to d2 here is a it's
a good move
okay so you can't even take it which is
a major issue in the game he tried
rookie two so that if you get my night
away I at least control the d2 squared
but now he goes here
and we went back now if here we have
here so he went back just King up six
and it's remarkably difficult for white
to move so he didn't he resigned in this
position and yeah spend as much time as
you want looking at this it's like
basically zugzwang here you can't move
anything so I don't even know what to
suggest for white I'll play anything you
guys want but I mean it's fascinating
already that's just so bad that he had
had enough in this position and it all
goes back to this very decision yeah
there's lots of checkmating threats so
you got to be really careful and you're
probably losing some stuff it all goes
back to this position in this decision
to trade the dark-squared bishop and he
was able to make use of this fact you
know he's got the dark-squared bishop
and okay another brilliant conception
bring the bishop over to the other side
of the board and then conquer the d-file
and suddenly all of his pieces are a lot
more active than whites and he was able
to convert it without any serious
difficulty alright let's look at another
game here well we'll flip it will give
white a chance to win this is the game
between Vladimir Kramnik and Judit
Polgar it was played in 1997 okay it was
game in 60 minutes alright so again
we're not going to focus on the opening
so much but here we see it's sort of the
exchange variation where we get these
pawns that we were looking at and again
sort of the strategy for white is to go
after this focal point here d6 and black
has different ways to try to break the
bind so we'll see what was chosen okay
rook e8 is the most popular move
provoking f3 and we'll see what plan she
decides to choose
okay so she goes after the pond and all
of this is theory so the night goes back
and now a five a forward to kick the
night away so all of this is theory so
we won't focus too much on it but here
however she made a very interesting
decision
almost everybody plays queen d8 and this
is still theory but I wanted to pick
this game you know an upon structure
lecture because what square should we
all be looking at when she played c5 d5
this is going to be the focal point for
the rest of this entire game and I
suppose she figured okay I understand
that I've created a weakness I have a
backwards pawn on d6 I get it but I'm
hoping to immediately get some activity
for my pieces for example now I can play
Knight here Bishop here go after the
pawn I can kick your your knight to a
bad square okay your knight has to go to
square like c1 and maybe I can do
something immediately but kramnik being
super grandmaster that he is he was able
to coordinate his pieces and then
ultimately exploit the d5 square so
that's going to be the theme of the game
we'll see how he did it
okay she brings the knight in and then
the next move is there should be six and
then something takes so rip d1 so that
you can meet Bishop e6 with b3 takes
takes all right
I please rook d1 now I can move my
knight and we can trade Queens and okay
it's always an interesting decision in
any game I mean who wants to trade the
Queens I think here it's actually
Kramnik so he moves his Knight - you
know attacking the square he wants to
trade the Queens and I'm just going to
focus this is the only advantage I need
and you you know this one weakness here
and then eventually I'm going to control
it then I'm going to take advantage of
this guy and he's able to do these
things so we'll we'll see how this
happens
all right I'm attacking this twice so
you have to play move like 98
a very interesting maneuver all right so
the night's going here royal control d5
and f5 you have to do something like
this it's you know you got to break the
bind down you guys somehow eventually be
able to play a move like d5 so I think
this is a good choice however after the
recapture this Bishop won't be able to
stay here forever
it is a nice diagonal reasonably good
diagonal but it's not permanent
g4 and okay you can see the white just
has a totally dominant position here I'm
controlling all of the important squares
and in black you'll will never play d5
so okay we go after the pond is
protected b6
so you're solidifying c5 maybe you can
go here but now also occasionally there
could be some ideas on this diagonal
you'll notice how right now this doesn't
quite work because it allows d5 but it's
something we want to want to keep in
mind as King G to h6 and this is
actually a very bad move white had a
very good position but now he actually
turns it into a huge advantage how do we
exploit this move h6 sort of hinted at
it yeah now Bishop d3 because it comes
with tempo so she played g5 and Bishop
e4 so the other she led the the best
Bishop come to an even better more
active square just unfortunate for her
and then
to make matters worse she okay she's
getting sick of these nights she's
willing to pay the cost of a dark
squared Bishop however now there's also
going to be ideas of like h4 and you
know breaking that open which is exactly
what happens and what is is probably
winning already this is just such an
advantage here
I know Bishop g5 so now okay click some
more stuff I don't think it lasts to too
much longer well yeah now it plays
another excellent move here we've been
sort of avoiding actually using the
square for any of our pieces because we
never want a situation where black can
take and we definitely you know take
back with a pawn at least normally
that's true however here Knight to d5
was played so we have some ideas so she
ended up taking and yeah you might
expect that Bishop takes Bishop takes
rook takes took what the pond very
concrete yeah yeah I get that Bishop out
and okay and now it's it's over and this
was great to you obviously you can take
the road this is even stronger
yeah those great move to and then yeah
Brooke h1 wins this totally wins the
point is now if you're here I mean okay
so that's that's the game so here she
gave it up and it comes back to this
move that she played early on there's a
very committal decision c5 you know you
you really better have something
concrete if you play this and maybe she
did had something prepared who knows but
it also is a relatively quick game you
know sixty minutes but uh it all comes
back to that
and even though white initially had to
put his pieces and okay not the dream
square they actually found all the right
squares quite naturally which is okay so
we get all of our Knights all the right
squares
and then okay then she even let the the
bishop you took a square and all right
this is so is a very well played
positional game by my kramnik as he as
he does sometimes he tends to do that so
we will look at one more game and we'll
look at the mainline Kings Indian here
okay it will make one remove so this is
a game Korchnoi Fisher this was a blitz
game and it was played in nineteen
seventy and remember that it's a blitz
game because he comes up with some
pretty fantastic stuff even though it's
a you know pass game gave me five
minutes
ninety two that you know used to be a
popular move it's not so popular anymore
and this case isn't this game isn't a
good case for you should be playing 92
in this position but it's very
interesting system and a very
interesting move c5 I think this is
quite an interesting way to play the
idea is to slow down White's play on the
Queen side as we'll see so now even if
you get these moves in this can be met
with a move like b6 that's the idea and
okay when you have space like this it's
obviously white that wants to play on
the Queen side necessary have more space
you want to break through there blacks
going to move his Knight and you can try
play F 5 F 4 and these pawns are going
to try to go like this and deliver
checkmate okay so these things all kind
of happened so b6 now if you take I can
take with my be pawn you don't get a big
monster pass pawn and f5
and in this game what just never really
gets anything going on the queenside
which is this is sort of you know a nice
model game if you're trying to play
Kings Indian okay f3 very common so if I
take care you can take back with a pond
and the open that file would mean we
would trade rooks and it's harder to
make me if we trade a lot of stuff so he
played off for a for you can play for a
five at some point you know okay you're
going to open up the B file or so you're
going to do something the black is just
quicker in this game you place the g5
a-five we can see the race and there's
lots of unusual maneuvers that you see
in the Kings Indian that you don't see
in a lot of other openings obviously h5
here is a good move but you please rook
f6 and he's going to go to g6 we can see
there's often funny maneuvers like this
or sometimes the bishop moves and the
rook from here can slide over to g8 you
see all sorts of interesting maneuvers
in these kinds of positions okay white
opens the B file but they're still not
really too much cause for concern white
is still a long way from doing anything
over there you can obviously you can try
to play a six I mean it doesn't matter
the pond doesn't matter black will
probably not even take it but how are
you going to get your pieces into action
over there I guess this guy has a good
square or you know what are you going to
do it's not so obvious but uh but
Fischer's plan is pretty obvious I'm
going to checkmate you that's the plan
Bishop d2 okay somehow you're gonna play
like these moves and maybe you're going
to get some stuff going on it's still
quite a long way away and here h5 would
just be normal normal good move but he
waited and he just played g4 and this is
sort of an issue because you kind of
have to take if some legal move and just
g3 and stuff is going to open up because
after h3 I think you're the very typical
sacrifice does work when you play the
black side of the King's Indian and they
play h3 you you take it in here yeah
this this looks pretty good so so you
got to worry about these things
which is why in the game he felt
compelled to take it so we take back
sure
age six
it's my wife she's from the she probably
she flew to Florida today hey lovey all
right cool yep what's that all right
love you
good all right love you very much uh no
we're filming right now well I'll call
you again tonight all right love you bye
all right she's safe for the record
she's safe
woof okay so here you play h3 there's a
pin so we don't have to move the night
immediately so he gets this other night
into the game
okay so we're seeing you know blacks
made a little progress we've opened up
the kingside a little bit but okay how
are you gonna you know really finish me
off and here this is a blitz cam
remember so pause your videos take 50
minutes and see if you can find what he
played in probably five seconds so here
comes up with a very brilliant maneuver
and again there's probably a lot of
moves to consider here and a lot of
different plans but it is sort of a
long-term plan and he comes up with a
very interesting maneuver and I think
once you see it you'll appreciate just
how strong it really is okay it's black
to move play like Bobby Fischer you want
to go back to g4 even though it's
there's not even a pin there anymore
okay okay with that one's out got it
yeah it's a blitz game so most of the
blitz games here that would be the
normal continuation nine to h4 I think
it's actually one of the moves to be
considered if I'm really going and I
think this is yeah I think this is okay
plan I think this is one of the things
computer wanted to do so this is fine
but then where are you going from here
okay you got your night there are you
really ever going to take here it's hard
to you know move your your rook and get
more attacks here because your knight
would be hanging on h4 I mean this is
just an okay move though I mean but he
had something even deeper yeah exactly 9
h8 f7 g5 but you know in attacking all
this stuff here there's gonna be some
sacrifices and that's going to be the
game yeah Fischer sacrifice you know I
mean yeah you'll notice a lot of
aggressive players throughout history
they've liked the King's Indian you know
it's you get to attack so that's that's
what you see this all happened and he
got all prepared and then he did it and
now black is winning all right and I
think this was the last move here I'm
attacking your queen also my queen
enters the game and your your king is
not going too far away he's going to
stay over here on this side of the board
yeah yeah you play 9h8 in the Blitz game
so yeah I hope this gives you guys sort
of an idea in this game too of let's
just recap it very briefly here I think
a very interesting moment was even this
early on he plays the move c5 and white
just never got anything going
so if white never gets anything going
you just get a free attack and that's
exactly what happened
and then he's bobby fisher' so the
attack you know worked out red moving
all your pawns just move in rooks up and
ran to places yeah you get all these
funny maneuvers but uh yes you have to
be sort of creative and imaginative if
you want to play this way as black but I
think it's it is good for certain people
especially if you just never tried it
it's good it just gets you you know it
can really inspire you to play sort of
unusual and think a little bit different
about chess because it's all about
giving checkmate and attacking in these
kinds of positions and you know we want
to play g4 how are we going to do it
rook up and over that's how you play
this opening well I hope you guys like
that one again let me know in the
comments below what other pawn
structures do you guys want to see as
always hit like share subscribe and I'll
see you guys next week